fortnight has become so incredibly
massive and all-encompassing that people
who have never even heard of the game
have been subjected to articles and news
pieces flooding their feeds and plastic
llamas wandering their streets but in
the lead-up to fortnight season five
epic games created an Arg or alternate
reality game where the game world and
our world really did collide it kicked
off with the shared world event of
season fours rocket launch that created
tears in the game sky eventually leading
to the current worlds collide event in
season 5 there were tons of hints and
clues for inquisitive players to
discover within the game and even in the
real world so if you weren't glued to
the subreddit like me or are just
getting into fortnight now here's why
the new season was so hyped and why you
may have seen news stories about giant
burgers appearing in the desert
throughout June 2018 there were plenty
of teases that a rocket would be
launched by the visitor the skin that
was earned as a reward for completing
seven blockbuster season four challenges
can down clucksten skulls were displayed
on TVs and rocket schematics was seen in
bases but on the 29th of June epic gave
players a message getting match on
Saturday by 10:30 a.m. Pt 1:30 p.m. ET
7:30 p.m. CET and look to the sky it
only happens once
of course players swarmed into service
to see what was going on many was so
enthralled that dozens of people even
dropped their arms to stare at the stars
on viewing platforms which other players
took advantage of
as the rocket launched and traveled
through the skies of a fortnight's
island rift started appearing in the sky
culminating in one huge crack above the
map which slowly expanded over the days
following during this launch sequence
two audio files were heard in the
background
crafty players were then able to
discover data within those audio files
using a spectrogram the first audio
sequence showed the skulls that were
also present on the countdown TV screens
while the second showed two sets of
numbers that were decoded to show four
different coordinates on the map and B 6
h 9i 8 and i 9 they were originally
believed to be a hint to a new game mode
to see off season 4 but the coordinates
ended up matching up with rifts and
items appearing or disappearing like the
appearance of an anchor at B 6 and an
old-time carriage at I 8 of course now
that we can see the whole season 5 map
we know that a Viking ship in town
appears at B 6 and the last three
coordinates are now home to the new
desert biome with objects vanishing from
the map and others unexpectedly
appearing people start to pay closer
attention to the subtleties of four
nights world but perhaps the most
interesting incident actually manifested
in the real world itself on the 6th of
July the user seller Salone on Twitter
tweeted what is this I'm in the middle
of the desert why is this here with an
attached picture of the derp burger
which had previously vanished from the
forum map via one of the rift anomalies
also present in the Californian desert
was one of the fortnight police cars
[Music]
soon after that discovery agents started
appearing on sites putting up a tent
scattered with items and surrounding the
burger with caution tape once agents had
started appearing on the scene crowds
followed Reddit user boy e QQ Hugh
captured an interaction with agent 3 6 7
8 in the video you can see the agent
hand out card that card had the number 7
1 2 3 a 0 4 0 9 1 if that number was
called after the 8th of July this
admittedly not very pleasant noise would
play
[Music]
following the pattern sneaky game
detectives took from the rocket launch
audio files this sound was put under a
spectrogram to reveal a similar code
this time the numbers were decoded to
show the coordinate of c7 the location
of greasy Grove and the spot where the
derp burger vanished from the game world
the ID numbers of the agents were also
an easter-egg themselves typing each of
the numbers into a phone's keypad would
reveal the words fort night and epoch do
you know anything about season five
season five of what three days later on
the 9th of July supply llama started to
appear in seemingly random locations in
Europe one in Cologne Germany another
found in Barcelona Spain one in Warsaw
Poland two in London England and one in
Cannes France the seventh was only found
after a new sound fire was discovered
when calling the number on the agents
card dialling six after calling the
number would play a new sound and
putting that audio into a spectrogram in
the same way the previous sound files
had been treated revealed the
coordinates of the seventh llama
following those coordinates it was
finally found in Paris France although
the game detectives wiki currently lists
it as robbed /m I a so some someone
steal a llama after that we only had to
wait until the 12th of July until things
started to make sense the build-up was
to the season five worlds collide event
skins and carts and objects and
buildings were brought from our real
world and into fortnight and apparently
in exchange we got llamas and giant
burger but if there's one game that
benefits from the excitement of
colliding worlds right now it's for
night the buzz and hype around the game
is in a constant ebb and flow it's been
a long time since I've seen mainstream
media report on a game like this in such
a big way or a game be talked about in
such common parlance it's as much a
phenomenon as any media property can
rightly become but why did people get so
caught up in countdown clogs rockets and
plastic alarms and phone booths for me
at least it showcased the infectious
curiosity of the community and the
creativity that's possible in a game
like this when its developer cares and
is willing to put in the effort to
engage its audience in more interesting
ways the biggest achievement of this Arg
is to strengthen four-night as a game
that offers more than just a core
gameplay loop of loot
building and trying to be the sole
survivor when you step back and look at
it there are many games that have either
done individual elements of these or all
of them together in a similar fashion
but what this Arg does is show for
tonight as a game with a world that
people are attached to characters
cosmetics and even dances that have
become recognizable we dare say iconic
but our games are a dime a dozen right
now but none of them have people
discussing the actual world they take
place in or taking selfies with objects
that have slipped into our real world
that this one island can be full of
intrigue and mystery that there's things
to find see and discuss and that plots
and stories can be given to what in many
other games would be purely cosmetic
skins is an impressive achievement and
undoubtedly the clearest indication the
battery our games can offer much more
than the thrill of victory from what I
saw most the community loved the Arg
there were many that dismissed it as a
PR stunt which is fair enough but in
many ways that's all Arg severa
in this case it triggered discussion and
teamwork and interesting conversations
and theories within the community the
fortnight be our subreddit was an
exciting place to be during the event
and seeing people's genuine excitement
and predictions was infectious as was
seeing the video where players banded
together to create a viewing platform to
share it still fills me with glee just
seeing those guys fall though oh my god
things like this both galvanized
community as well as create intrigue
outside of the playerbase it makes for
fun stories to tell I was there during
the rocket launch I'm at the agent in
the desert
I saw the llama in London's Covent
Garden it would be easy for epoch to sit
on their laurels happy that their game
is doing so exceptionally well but they
keep finding new and interesting ways to
not only excite that current player base
but intrigue a much wider audience and
that is something I would love to see
more I'd like to thank both a four-night
battery our subreddit the game
detectives wiki who did such a good job
at investigating each tidbit of
information as well as all the curious
and inquisitive for my fans who took
pictures visited locations and shot
videos your enthusiasm was infectious
and what really made this Arg great I
hope you enjoyed this video about what I
thought was a rather fascinating event
for the community but for more
four-night content make sure you stay
tuned to GameSpot
[Music]